About Saree Leadership
Amount
were also arrested, all of them
in custody but
are made
And did he make any request to them?
He must be looking after the bail given.
I have joined Shazeb for 2 weeks.
Imran Khan has got bail but now
Majeed, the cases which are in his knowledge
Imran Khan's family will get bail for him
The society is continuing on the request of Aap Surat Kya
We are seeing that the chief should be arrested and there is power.
How else is Imran Khan alive or not?
will happen
in which we could see
And
I wonder how the same thing happened to you too
number of cases against them
very my brother in law's name
be winded and
Arrested
I think this is better than that, my Muslim.
But this will also be some fear from you, Wazir.
Azam never even did a book and it became bigger.
Table He said that I have great emotions
I am here and I am speaking from my heart.
How will you tell it to happen?
Victimization has been happening and no one is responsible for that.
No action was taken
He mixed what Imran Khan got bail
And sir, you can read it like this
How are you looking at the political front?
What
This is a big question of governance and
it's about gold
From now onwards there were demands for people's release
Inquiry statements were not received
yes it was a caste
Notice is being issued at the inquiry stage
happened after
The situation is such that answers to caller notices are given.
I he didn't go first
are apart from
They were also doing soaps for him.
Target them on your food with spite
If it is done then it will be a part of the country's history.
You are there but the spice is that you should change but
They
to talk about
how totake
it was the day before yesterday
Sir, the Supreme Court has taken an order and
for 11 hours
I have a saree in the Supreme Court
There is bail in all the cases that I
Supreme cannot be arrested
Court 11 hours
Didn't even listen and he came out of the Supreme Court
and were arrested but
When someone's son-in-law burns the siege in two days
Today the building was filled with water and vehicles
and people
This is the track record of
It means that if I am cheated then the same will happen in the future also.
And that's not even content on your account.
If you are doing it then make great use of it.
Because he is not like that from the court
She is learning and I am not saying that
He is fully prepared in every possible way.
The Supreme Court along with the Supreme Court
The treatment you gave to Chaudhary
lotus with both
No there is no other than that there is a star
Supreme Court asked questions for 11 hours
this can't happen
And it is different for a small leader 11
till the hour your
We looked at what happened outside
Shehzad Iqbal has also joined us
Hey Munib, you are saying this to me.
Imran Khan's arrest is possible tomorrow
Rana Sanaullah
Also gave interviews and he especially
By the way, all those who have experienced this situation
See, burn it in two days under siege.
He said that according to the law
Action will be taken but in particular he
Once in Lahore which is a big yes
It was a building which also had a historical background.
He said, give today hearing on this
The case will be run on the basis of and on that we
If you definitely arrest me then you have the power.
Imran Khan's arrest today
See
Imran Khan Sahab must be arrested
have power
The bail he has got now is from the one who will be there tomorrow
For them
release
The thing about the couple in it was that one
The Supreme Court was absolutely right
said that
understand the method of their arrest
I have been with all of us since day one that he is-
The facility that Imran Khan Sahab got
He has been given protection by the court.
This is their protection
status
it was done, he went to court
To take bail or under some bail
to extend but the court
Who specifically gave them protection?
So that they don't have to face any other case of mine.
can wait
Everyone has got two weeks bail, warrant
Perhaps there is still no one above the majority
There was no debate but what remains is the fate.
Some more of them and compressing bail gesture
I can't find the strength and I have it on my hands
cases registered in lahore
It cannot be said from him that
Those who believe in your entire Pakistan
Which is and which have been filed in previous taxes
A court blanket over both of them
I ordered it and we gave it to you in full.
If this happens today then this too
A new jersey but that probably won't happen
Because look at that case which
Those who have been registered inside Lahore
Rejection Lahore Kia Dalton Ki Bunty Hai
Lahore High Court Bench of Lahore is divided
or let's go
islamabad hi
court
But this is absolutely true that by eating it we
Can't reduce Imran Khan Sahab's taxes
Cases have also been made against Puri at this time
Efforts are also being made to make them as Indian as possible.
arrest them
You have to ask questions tomorrow also, you are very deep inside.
He was telling me that Shahzad is also with us.
Shazeb is also with us but here is a
This is important news that you have shared with your viewers.
Chairman PTI Imran Khan has to deliver
Gave relief from Supreme Court
Imran has been raided on a Sahafi question
Khan said that there is no answer to his arrest
Wasn't he loyal? Jai Jai Jaar
Warrants should be shown like this in the law of the jungle
It's like it's happening in the country
Imran Khan has become Marshal and Nafees
Said
Life was given relief from Supreme Court
Imran turned face on a question of cleanliness
Khan said that there is no answer to his arrest
They were blown away by Jai Jai.
The warrant will show that this would have happened in the law of the jungle.
Is
My times I am shown the signs when
This jungle takes me to victory
It is in the law of, that is, where has the law gone?
One
It's the law of the jungle, but it's going like this.
Kind of like a martial arts declarer here
Done
and you think 40 people me
So the first Pantafa address reached the court yesterday
Let's say 40 people millet
Oh dear, I don't even know this.
Listen to Imran Khan's anger
On behalf of the Supreme Court, he
Relieved life's fate has been raided
Our translation process is going well
Hai Shahzeb Saheb, Muneeb Saheb and Shehzade
Iqbal Saheb is with us, Munim is a legal
Wait, please clarify before I stop.
Let us carry on the conversation when tomorrow the Supreme
The court's decision came and the order came.
After that this great Imam was born who
The conversation which is to end today in High Court
Which obviously our application was submitted
his legal affairs ended
What is the standing or if you are legal?
But if we look, is there any such example?
How did he get the Supreme Court?
Have ordered and then Islamabad hi
An application was made to the court and
To end
That earlier measurement was not in the law but now
The vote of first is at the bottom if
If you have to go then don't go now if you have the power first.
this used to happen
Bail in law inside High Court
provision
Imran Khan Sahab's situation has become cloudy
This is the class mockup
Came inside to get bail for me
I don't know, I haven't seen that record.
But who knows what they say if I am right about them
Yes, but the objection was fundamentally the same.
And perhaps it was done today too, Advocate General Saheb.
Oh my god, this is not a [ __ ].
You can get bail directly here
For Warrantly Also Jain So You Below
You go directly to the High Court.
What have you come to get but because this
Special is a circumstance and he said red
There was also a file from Amchur recently if anyone
If you are an individual then I don't think so.
The court which the court normally says that you
Let us go to the relevant forum first.
If someone like Ram Saheb gives you bail,
The power is given, the court also gives that
We will give you a protecting mail.
It's been two days since you appeared in court.
whatever forum there is
Jain but here a silly thing has started
I will say it the second time because tomorrow
The order has arrived. If you read the order, I
I said this yesterday also, I will say this today also
How should the report now be made to the Supreme
There is a court and a reported judgment should be made.
So that the status given by the court
If a person did not have that status then he
He provided that means who gave the bail?
The court found him out and in what way?
no just can't get arrested and you're wrong
Jain should also go but if the circumstances are at stake
How did you take it? Please give yours. Yes, yours.
The arrest city is a colony and I also say
That's right, my friend is from Delhi.
Fine Imran Khan Saheb Freeman Ji Din Woh
Went to Islamabad High Court and got no
to arrest
It was meant for whom but it was meant for him.
Supreme Court had no time
put them in the wheel by hand
so sister
If this release is made in every corner of Pakistan
If you start dating a high profile man
This is a new perspective, that's why I say that
This decision should be reported to you and
I stand by what I said yesterday also
was and did that ended yesterday but which
The method was done and the decision was taken first.
He had left the scenery with us.
If there is only staff then Jaikara Veer joins in front.
I have done it sir, you tell me, the question is this.
Are you seeing Imran Khan arrested?
Is anyone else in it or not?
Will be arrested and how did it go like this
The matter will remain in its technical hands also.
And Imran Khan will come and the world will be yours.
Will remain in other ongoing cases also
This was when Imran Khan Sahab was afraid a little while ago.
Friendship is guaranteed, so after that I
Wafa's rule and Punjab rule
There are sources, I have talked to them and Imran Khan
Sir
I have spoken
First thing is that Imran Khan
Sir was arrested that day
The arrest which I told you immediately after
It was said that this arrest was wrongly registered.
How did it happen and Imran was arrested in this
Khan's bail was bound to be changed and he
It's done but now they have to wait for two weeks.
Bail has been granted and with this bail he
Some fear ago Wazir Azam Shahbaz Sharif Saheb who
His hot book is all those TVs.
You saw it on the channel and before that Rana
Election sir had also announced that we will
will arrest away
Who
The news has come after that all over Islamabad
Sir is sitting loudly and one who is federal
Minister is very scenery Federal Minister
They are what I want. We need them.
May we never lose our fun
And the Supreme Court also has to do whatever you want.
but after that
Talked to another minister and then
My administration of Islamabad
And the police are there, so there is talk.
The news I have is that right now
In Islamabad Police and Punjab Police
After the fight, Imran Khan was arrested
who will do
Islamabad police is ready to arrest
Because there is pressure from Islamabad Police
That Imran Khan should be arrested under any circumstances.
What has to be done when Punjab Police is there?
She has arrived and is standing outside the high court.
Yes and she belongs to G.K.
Imran Khan sahib is busy with us and this is this
Look, here we have his name in it.
If you want to catch it then it's no longer a matter of not catching it.
Because it has become the spice of respect because
Wazir Alam Saheb, Wazir Dakhla Saheb said so much
Had made big claims so far
Imran Khan could not do anything
Has anything happened with the story?
A suggestion has come that an emergency should be imposed.
it is like this
But
Come, the stable news at this time is that
What is Islamabad Police and Punjab Police?
There is a quarrel among ourselves and I am the one who quarreled.
I am using words, that is not me.
Idioms to use, not to use
There is divergence between two police forces.
There was a proper argument and they talked on the phone earlier.
It should be said that the blood was not reducing then that
Don't talk to each other over regular food
See, even police officers are afraid of this.
If we talked on the telephone then the story
WhatsApp is not working please don't record
Then he came for his money
The meeting point is Islamabad.
Whatever happened outside the court, they did it to each other.
We talked, met while standing on the road and
They got into an argument, you became the source of the fight.
Islamabad is not using it like this
There is a fight between the police and Punjab Police
What if someone arrests Imran Khan?
This is their decision now, Imran
Who will arrest Khan first?
Who is more quick to arrest?
But it's my way, Imran Khan Sahab.
were first arrested and then
First the Supreme Court gave relief, now
Islamabad High Court released him
If he is arrested in such a case
Will do in which their name is the same
Is there any other case filed by the police?
During his detention in Lahore
If it happens, if they are arrested without evidence
If they do then they will get what they have again.
Any caste will get release from court
Rahmat in some Dev Buniyaad case
Should not be arrested and if arrested
If you want to do it, then arrest him properly.
Do it but if you don't do it in a non way
If we arrest then this will happen that at this time
Wazir Azam Saheb and his Wazir Dakhla Saheb
Those who are there do not understand where we are
go, therefore told the IG that under all circumstances
catch him
I wanted this, it is your news that
Brother, hold on to everything but cooking.
foundation what what
How come there are so many cases on them?
among them or this one now
Those with words have become mujahids in connection with that.
something may happen in
[music]
He told the Islamabad policemen that
show file
What cases are there to file in the police?
I don't know this
Because I did not have that document
Good but Wazir to Islamabad Police
Azam and Wazir admission
Catch us as soon as the Quran comes out
It is definitely there but inside which is Imran Khan Sahab's
He has taken it out and he told me this.
He is very relaxed and he is from here.
We have given it in Lahore also
I also told the lawyer that you are in Lahore.
Hi Court Jain and come to him as much as possible
There is information that he is there also
We have worked hard and here too
The time has come when a lawyer, Imran Khan Sahab,
are present together
The communication I have with them
He just told us that we will leave the court now.
Those who are not coming out without cases
we are among them too
How and when will they start asking for bail?
Do you want to put a blanket or
Some Majid for those who are facing other cases
getting extended
details of
Islamabad Police and currently Punjab Police
What is happening is that we have a
Both have cases to arrest.
The current prince is yours, these cases are possible
But anyway, the cases that came later are known.
All the cases that were made before 3 days
They are theirs before tax day.
They are there and they are also going against them.
For bail, this is Moong Ki Raat Tor.
There may be cases in which three
Circumstances, sentence has been passed and bail is sought.
To know how to do Ruju
Many cases of criminal lawyer are necessary
They are such that you don't know their origin.
and you are rested
According to him it was clear that the police
Will I be doing this match or not?
have to tell
three-four days
Chaudhary Saheb
And sir and the best way to go home to Sri Lanka
He has been arrested from LPU
It is divided under i.e.
The public decides in such a way that
Due to which they had to move to another place
Maybe I am arrested for this situation.
It has become apparent that the government
By the way, everyone is arrested because of this thing.
There are promises so that
I don't want to get arrested
If I am arrested then Surat
Even today he
Said that if I am arrested then
Then the situation will be the same as before
kept doing
It is ahead but the government has to prove it with evidence.
It will have to be done that Khan Saheb is behind everything.
It is with Khan Saheb that I was there.
No, I didn't even have a phone and I
so fall
I am ready to bring it
Shahzad Mir Sahab has just informed us
And these big news Islamabad Police and
There is a fight in Punjab Police, Wazir A
According to Azam Saheb and Wazir e Dafa soap
They want the arrest of Imran Khan
Now who has to arrest Imran Khan?
will arrest there is a dispute over this
On the other side is Imran Khan's who is tomorrow.
Imran Khan does not want to be arrested
And asking for obvious reasons and bail
These Jabo Garibs have been great in every way.
The appearance is the condition, how are you looking at it?
Are
Look, you have given us great news, we are rich.
That at present in Punjab Police and Savat Police
There is a dispute that Imran Khan
Who will arrest the bail given at this time?
How can I trust Alka? That's Imran Khan.
Sir has got it and in figure cases too
Maybe he will try to take Priya in the race
If we are living without then no one wants such a case.
Whether it is corruption or someone else, it remains to be seen.
Now if you don't care about Imran Khan
If you look at this time, who is trying to arrest him?
After the situation arose in unbeaten or Punjab's
Were others born among lions and handed over to him?
they will be arrested from or as
He is the heart of Pakistan, isn't he the MP?
He is being arrested under
Arrest will be made, see if today
This means that in any case, in any case
If I am arresting Imran Khan then
Then we will not think about the matter and
We are seeing that it will get entangled from tomorrow because now
Army also deployed under Article 245
So some peace has come but if not all
it's just that
Imran Khan should not be arrested in any case
should not be done
Imran Khan himself had also said that
Arrested, there is a power in their implementation, now this
Big news comes from Islamabad High Court
It is said that the court has ordered that
17 I want justice for Imran Khan
to someone
No new cases should be filed inside Imran
Khan should not be arrested till 17
Islamabad High Court
In the situation that has happened, people have surrounded themselves with water.
did and certainly from Nakumatt's side and
78 cases of panic by liquor
If you have also registered then now Imran will be till 17th.
Khan should not be arrested in any new case
Islamabad has been instructed to do
This is also Badi Aap from Hi Court
Because Imran Khan had said that he
will be arrested
Imran Khan arrested in a new case
Let's do!
which is islamabad police and punjab police
Both comes standing outside the wealth and
The dispute is about who appointed Imran Khan
President ways justice to arrest
I myself had mentioned this
Rana Saheb is with us, you have a
You gave interviews yesterday also and said that today Surat
Relief will arrest Imran Khan
will be found and then arrested so that we can
tell everyone to expose the stars
What's the time like?
If there is a case against Imran Khan then
is recorded if it gives in all of them
Ram will try to become whatever he is.
be empty and if what is there is in some way
Gives and how can anyone be whatever he is even after that
If it exists then of course we can call it
They will arrest someone in this situation
No
has come
Whoever is in the back three
someone's for these
There will be no rest from the government side
The facility they get from Aaliya
They are being welcomed.
Being flattered is best for them
It's okay to express something special.
Do what you want but according to the law
According to what we could, their guards and
We are against anti state activities
do
Up to 17 arrested in any new case
You people have rocked Imran Khan by doing this.
did you want to arrest him
Islamabad Police Assistance outside the court
was standing
Islamabad Police also comes and is present there
If Railways exists and if so then the orders
Who has sense in the case?
not to be arrested
Whatever is the date, it is as per that.
will be implemented because there are
They are seriously official.
It has been said that those who are Advocate General and
Secondly, you are present there as the scenery.
To seek guidance from them and order from the court
Saturn is what it should be.
Fulfill your responsibilities accordingly
And if there is someone to arrest Imran Khan
The answer is divided despite the court's decision.
Then it will definitely be done with and if not
Banta is fine then that
There can be no other answer like this in the face of feast or
There may be a case in which time will prevail.
should not be done and should be immediately arrested
I was just going to talk, then I interrupted.
I am your yesterday, I am still here
The mission is what is on your screen.
those who
How is Al Kader Trust related to corruption?
So what is there is that they get bail for two weeks.
is given and after that it is said that
Maybe till 17 he will face some other case also
Don't be arrested, whatever is, whatever is.
Now it has been granted that I am not confirmed in this matter.
I can do that given my ability, every one of them
The President is going to be the Supreme Court tomorrow
I also had someone in the last 707 days
There is no parallel but no less in the world.
Is available and this order is also
There is no example, there would have been others like this
No but let's go if we become this new thing.
What's new and what's new
the one who is opposite
Opinions are being invented so let's go.
give this again
If this money is not for my beloved then will it?
When we go to the field, all these things happen again.
It will be for Muslims then everyone should want that
leave less, just work hard
Have worked hard and every town has a few 100 people
There is definitely no more than 100-150 in it.
And you prepare them one by one and spice them up.
And whatever happens after that, you can do whatever you want.
Wait whenever and however you want.
You government should fix those people's houses today.
You can do whatever you want and no one will ask you.
won't happen
Who is the President of this Kim?
If you don't want to release what you have,
If I go and this record is a thing, then it is mine.
Pay for the motherfucker's boxes and then you will have a seat.
will go
By the way, you said that according to the law
Hoghra Khan was arrested but
How did you mention a particular thing at one place?
While doing this you said that the one which was in Lahore
Where to burn the building? We are surrounded there.
Will definitely arrest and put him in that again
Today you said that he will also have a hearing.
Is Amar Mila arrested after 17?
will go
Yes of course if till 17 which is on your screen
It's not on the 17th, in any way
If arrest is considered 17
As soon as this order becomes a lawyer because a
Evidence is available for every day of the entire year
When people were traded their names were Alka
were registered and for this purpose
What they have prepared is petrol bomb.
To make a gel, all these things are there, each one of them.
This is the evidence of the day and of Imran Khan Sahab.
Whatever your caste is, it is for every occasion of every day.
There is talk that if I get crushed then
Then you have to do this, then you have to do that
so that on them
exist in which it is said that the same
Not there.
If something happened, you did nothing.
He is under their direction and there is such
It is not that you will see these two-three days, right?
So all the sirs are waiting for what is there.
She was the Mrs. who had never met anyone before.
Itjaz's CMAT is gone and the second is that the houses
attack on now look at their house
Now all are present above my house which
Those who have come to Faisalabad, you, me?
Don't know where their homes are
sentence on
Imran Khan has created it with all his hard work
so its body
These two or three will not be there, will they?
Both of them have fasts, even after this what is there
this will continue further
[music]
What is and what was the order is the basis and the agency
whatever it is
Know your price and your responsibility
Whatever political party will complete it,
A new one which should be ordered by Imran Khan
Sir has made nectar which is absolutely perfect.
If he has gone then it is a political party which is political.
Whatever is for the party, whatever is for him too.
That will be monitored behind that this is less
It is a great opportunity that you can help thousands of people
Fire and grind to injure whatever is there.
Total 21 Bandas fired in entire city
After making friends and then doing whatever you want
Do whatever anyone asks you to do.
There will be no one but you wherever you go
you will be welcomed glad to see you
Best special gift will be given for you
It will be done, it is not a big task
Adequate treatment is not being done and there are big problems in it.
We are also the decision of the situation of the country at this time.
Are you considering such a decision?
can be taken into
In which there is definitely talk going on and
Ramta news
If given, do you understand what the circumstances are?
yes, are you feeling shy?
Don't see what's in it when
So it has come but till now the benefits of emergency
What is above has not been decided, yes?
These are yesterday's remarks and in a good way
Tomorrow a religion against which 60% of the population is now
Exam of corruption to raid the treasury
on whose reward people's houses were burnt
Jafai Tulsi you were attacked
Yes, he was welcomed yesterday.
kind of awaited her happiness
Is
She is from the cabinet and in this big
Whatever is there in this big whatever is this one whatever
legal
Whatever this thing is, whatever it is, Trivedi did it.
go and his
something happened
If there is an emergency center then there is no one in this big
As such
So it is the same but there is someone else in this big or
Is there any money related matter?
What will be your streets in future?
Rana Saheb, have we got some clarity or
what can you give
[music]
And the attacks that have been carried out on people's homes
All their little ones are present, one by one, who
He is 25 and whoever is against him is
The case that has been filed has been filed.
and brought against them completely
He has found his way and is someone Kim's.
in big
Is it far away or is it good Rana Saheb one more
Question: When will the situation become normal i.e. now
So in Islamabad and Pindi in Lahore
Pak army has also done flag march
If the soldier is under Article 245, then when?
There will be a rebellion, when will the situation become normal?
What information do you think you have?
Had Kareena been there, we had a complete idea that
What we are is what we are in two to three people.
Whatever appearance you have, control it.
Will give complete details in this article
I had already completed my saree, sir, let's see something.
it was over but yesterday
has been born
If it is caste till 17 then till 17 or 17
Then again and if it lasts for two weeks
Is
Please tell me about this problem you are facing.
When will I restore this to everyone?
At first we kept it for two-three days.
Had done this, now if this is the case then this
If it goes up to or beyond 17 then this
The one who is in big again is the Prime Minister
By taking finance from everyone, I
We have to make it this long
Because then other vices, those who
If you miss him then he is at his place
But what is justified by many people
Those people are also suffering losses.
Then we have to keep an eye on the money.
And the mosque also belongs to you that if 17
Surat al remains till or lasts for two weeks
If yes, then we will consider Majid, then this
The picture is surprising to the townspeople that this
The matter is neither going this nor that way
We are not going to arrest you even if it is yours.
can arrest them if you do
I found this, how is the situation happening?
Surely you too will have a picture on this.
we have big popular puri com with us
If at any place there is a B, there is a J
That upcoming is used people come out
The matter is that this is also the time to solve the problem.
On the day of Loafer toll, people are in trouble
Let's give whatever is there apart from them at some place
There are not more than 300 but
Services and this band must be done by him
I don't feel like caste and then you wrote the article.
Fast of 2245 if this is so much
If it was under control then those who are sitting at home
The urban common people are those who go there whenever they go.
So by giving screen and in big of surah
questions come to them
What I have described as their leader is bad.
Whatever it is, your camera is your reporter.
Will also be reporting to you, this is the case
Whatever this number is, it is just like this.
I have done this since but the matter is that
His head is mostly on social media.
sir gali gloss saree planning everything
If they do it on social media then that's why
He is on that side of the matter that was done.
Because of which I want to understand that the common man
also have a smiling face and kind manner
I said we were looking into it
so that whatever it is
What is missing in her smile
go
There is no law till date so don't you
Still believe that the situation will get better now
Do you have any expenses?
[music]
Today people's homes are affected by those who
Those who are above clean and fancy talk have a chance
Got it in such a way that perhaps it was understood that
I was not realizing that what they had was limited.
Even if there is power, when their identification
if it is done then theirs
I think it will take some time for the arrest to take place
It will cost but not that much
They may continue it to that extent
But we will try to get it done as soon as possible
He should go along with the common citizens.
in a smile
It came to pass that whatever happened continued for three days.
Yesterday I gave Adam the car as a son-in-law.
But it is being thought that this is also being discussed.
[music]
No one has found this thing yet
Indore was not done because before that
The one above the button shows a name of the cloud.
who is from the party
If it is a registered caste then no one belongs to it.
The decision has not been taken but this is my thought
that maybe this thing which
Rana Sanaullah Saheb was present with us
Thank you very much for your love and affection
were talking and telling about the future
What is the possible power of government and with
He was telling that this was definitely the intention.
That Imran Khan has to be arrested but
Now the expert general should take stock of this matter.
It is said that the Islamabad High Court has
Bail granted in new case till 17th
Imran Khan has been granted bail after that
How will Surat Hall turn out here?
But PTI Chairman will keep telling you this
Imran Khan gave relief from Supreme Court
Jaan's toss has been redid by a Sahafi
On question, Imran Khan said that his
There was no answer to the arrest.
It has been done, Jai will go and show the warrant, such a forest
It is said in the law of
As if the country has become Marshal and Nafees.
Chairman Khan said
Me
When the warrant is shown to me,
This jungle takes me to victory
It happens in the law of i.e. where
gone law
you are one
It's the law of the jungle, but it's going like this.
Kind of clear here a martial art
Went
Some 40 people saw me when I went to court yesterday.
Pantfa first arrived and found out that 40 people
making fun of it
don't even know
This was the opinion of the High Court that Imran
Khan should not be arrested for any new cases.
Imran Khan's instructions to see the reason declaration
let's repair what happened like
Ismian Golasan Aurangzeb said and
Islamabad High Court said that the state
Imran Khan's security is not assured
And he has said that after 9 I, Imran
Fear of any lawsuit against Khan
What happened in the case ends next
Who
When he prepared Imran Khan on the spot
If arrested then after his arrest
Mulagare happened and we
Case was also batched against Imran Khan
Since they had no idea about this
What is happening in the country?
Darkness
He was completely oblivious and said that Imran
By granting bail in that case of Khan also
The ones which are undisked or which we can get
No, but Islamabad High Court
The order has been issued and they have said that
Whatever happened to Imran Khan after his arrest
We should not arrest them
It was also said from the Jab of Samaj Adalat that
Whatever Imran Khan used to do in decoration
i.e. Imran Khan
of
Jai, apart from this, order has also been given in the court.
Imran Khan's security
don't trust them
It was stolen. They said it was a new one.
which stop
it
How is Imran Khan in this society now?
Bail is a tally, please clear it.
What has been said is that the declaration to Imran Khan
have to give
That they blame what has happened
David became tearful after writing that we will get the money deposited.
Then you will get bail, this is not the bail.
So let them see and order the bail.
But what about giving gravity?
Now he has remarked this
It depends on which return option is right.
Will it include or not
This is the thing that gives decoration.
justice
And the bail which has been approved is in the order.
This includes the decoration thing that
May they complete all kinds of today's things.
This part is reproduced in the order
Or not, all this in its own way
Not called good before the 9th
If the case is filed before the no.
If there is police to arrest him then
There is power in it i.e. which before 9
There is already a case going on in it
yes of course
[music]
When exactly has a case been filed and
If he is not on bail then hand him over
The court did not impose any restrictions
They have the power to arrest him.
Because this special thing happened in the court
What has happened is that 9 people have been arrested.
circumstances of happened and sentences
many cases have been filed
of which they have no idea and that
If he was in custody then how could he be involved in this case?
Is
If these lawsuits have happened because of them
Therefore, in these cases, even if they do not
I know but after his arrest it rained
It was always there that bail should be given.
Imran Khan's director Salman
And he said nothing more than this.
Have you given any broker or any general discussion took place?
The first of the 9 cases in the court
Imran Khan has bail in that
all
before
No matter what is known is the case
If there is a case then it cannot be filed but which
It is known that Imran Khan is involved in all those lawsuits.
is on bail
were updating and telling that the dialogue
Hi Court 17 till Imran Khan finds someone new
Instructed not to arrest in case
Imran Khan is going to give a declaration at o'clock, whatever
These remarks make up for what happened
Given by Justice Mia Gul Hasan Aurangzeb
Security of Imran Khan from state side
I am sure this is Islamabad too.
The court has ordered and also
Remarks given to him in court
The day Imran Khan was arrested
CCTV video of that day in court
CCTV video is not recorded
Let us have some clarity on this and then
Let's ask the above question, some new information has come.
Tax against Imran Khan in Lahore
Imran has to seek bail just to protect the case.
Khan from Courtroom Tu to Courtroom Four
Jai will take the money Chaudhary will follow the lawyer
We are planning to take action against Khan in Lahore.
The case is pending, now only HI Jat has got bail.
they have to take
Owais knows from him, please tell Faisal
Choudhary is telling that tax in Lahore
Jim is sued, this fancy bail has to be taken
In connection with this, now other clothes court
going in
Yes, absolutely not the liver cases that we have now.
He is like the court of Mohammad Jahangir
I am engaged for the society and you who
Like date Mohammad Jahangir but me
That is my single bench.
Will it be done and which cases will it go to?
Gee
but this is all that is said
Whatever has been done is good, now this too a little
Tell me now as you were telling me earlier.
Mutalli's CCTV from CCTV video
The record of his court day is missing
Has there been any notice on this or anything
funny minds come to the fore
He has shown a lot of concern and the court
Joe Advocate General in Islamabad
direct to them
He also said that the sentence which
What happened to him but this dude is okay
Whatever prayer he prayed for, he granted it.
The report is about when that mirror was collected from the society.
Okay, we are concerned about the court action.
Were telling that not only communication
High Court has given permission to Imran Khan till 17th.
Instructions not to arrest in new case
but also this task has been given to
Security of Principal Imran Khan is sure
Didn't make it and now the court room number is from you
Jai, take him out to court room number four.
Has been the president way justice because
There is talk of tax against him in Lahore
In which case bail is to be taken, in this regard
Whatever action I take in the future will be like my representation.
Will take details and reach you
You have decided never to jab 9 I
Pakistan's Musalla against Wakrad
This statement was supported by two
Mutableizer Declaration also states that
Terrorism against the state, these laws are useless
There should be no increase in rent from those who do this today.
We have reported this to you even before.
Did that in today's glass of acting
Who had 9 I's sentences with the question
But a lot of trouble has been done and it has been said that
When the houses are the buildings which are comical
and Rajyoga is being done to fulfill it.
What else do jackals have to destroy?
To stop the taste motor way radio
G's government and private including Pakistan
Lakhs and vehicles are jealous of government and taxes and
Like burning the ambulance after unloading the patient
all sentences
Can't say that all is well
against practice
Some [ __ ] is sure he is what he is.
Gave me my chance citing emergency
This current situation has become precedent in recent times.
The movie Paul Emergency Office should be done on ji.
Masjid Azam against PDM after this
But again this is based on a meeting.
Requested why not Space Mushairat
It can be done but no one bothers with questions.
The decision has not been taken yet.
There was a letter from Pakistan but in which
The one thing that mattered was that the life of the Justice
Nice to see you from Good Chairs
from my liver yesterday
I was polled and if the collection is possible
Kajal is more worried about the lawsuits.
But this bastard is ashamed
islam islam sir world
Cannot be done
Is
Some other decision may make sense
Hazrat, we are giving this news
Imran Khan has written a letter to Yusuf Azam
Find out from the arrest what happened to him
Kavin would rather attend the PDM meeting at this time.
There is going to be another meeting after this.
It will be fun in which we will take decisions
The flood has come for the night and as if
That we are telling you that the treatment of PF
Maulana Fazlur Rehman is praising it.
According to Zara's opinion, the country is in the meeting.
Political situation and court situation on our face
Mian is being sipped in this glass
Nawaz Sharif is Jari Sharif of video link
According to Zara, PDM's habit is al
Tips to be followed after Holi on crops
Our representative Waqar Sati will announce
Taksi Lal knows him who has joined us
Waqar is a lawyer, someone who is an expert on the inside.
Is
Maulana Fazlur Rehman definitely and on this
I have taken the decision of both of them
right on top of them
which treatment
What happened and the decision that came after that
You are also giving and the special thing about the treatment is also this.
Which is from Niyamabad Shiva London on this
video link
going to decide whose treatment
will be talked to
Take it all off, does anyone have any idea about this?
It is possible
The one who is Abor and the one who is Punjabi pee on him
is being done but what will be the decision now
When will he have time to say something?
As Rahman told us yesterday that we
Decisions will be taken from PF platform.
do
Those who were invited yesterday are from their own party.
Did we chat and was it about Tejas?
A Jain
That sir, that debate was held on that and which
We also have our own treatment for the court case.
Imran Khan Sahab in the right way from the court
He is getting relief in every case.
Sher Al Vo Best was given and this mandate
Maulana was found
to decide no matter what happens
We
Have to stand and in this context PDM
ever against
PM's President
Come MQM and HP this is PF's
This is not part of the offer, it is part of it
All those who deposit in PF and
His button displays include
What was the PM telling about, sir?
Is sitting together and what next hit mate only
Especially the court will be in the scales of crops
Musafir continues above that and before
Ayaz Akbar Yousafzai told us that this
After the glass of PDM, never again
There will be a meeting in which Majid will further present the government
What has to be done is up to him and will be done
The government will never sit with its heads folded at this time
Join us with the sign Tajiya
Hamid Mir Saheb Mir Saheb your news
Rana Sanaullah Saheb proved to be absolutely true.
some fear of you existed with us before
He said he absolutely intends to arrest
But now this new situation has arisen
It's been 17 months in a new case
Imran Khan cannot be arrested
What is your Tajiya after this?
The power is the only one of spades
I do
So let me stay married, I will only love you
I will just give you news
Just the news I told you earlier
What happened after the news is that
Islamabad Police should have blood of desires
I went because she was ready to take the bet.
That we caught Imran Khan but
Because now Islamabad High Court has released
Is giving Imran Khan up to 17 more years
All the cases against Imran Khan
Here in Islamabad, they
can't be arrested now
The Punjab Police is now removing them.
What to do with your government because
There are two lovers in it, one opinion is this
Which is the decision of the High Court
His
Whatever is there does not happen in the cases of Punjab.
But the second opinion is that Islamabad
Be it High Court or Lahore High Court.
If any decision is taken then its treatment will be complete.
happens in the country
punjab police aa punjab
The police are talking about it so they are legal
What they have from machines is something from them
More coming forward and one interesting
The thing is that those who are of the age of loyalty
Mushaira he also gave his
Started giving advice because now their
there is nothing left
What is the power of Punjab if there is a legal option?
Police or Islamabad who are giving options
For them
I am trying but my opinion
I can pace it now I think so much
You should not insist if you are supreme.
Imran Khan got relief from the court also
And also got release from Islamabad High Court
I have already told you this before.
of Islamabad Police and Punjab Police which is
She is in a dilemma at this time, so who?
First Imran Khan was arrested along with
I also told you this Imran Khan
I also talked to him about his books.
He is a big believer, he thinks that this
If you are arrested in any case, you
Punjab
Arrest him and get relief from the court.
You will get it, their legal point is this
That all the cases against us are very
He is weak, there are only two lawsuits, he is jeans.
He was looking a little worried
The word was that this case has not ended
The bail is done in this and the second one is about to be eaten.
So whatever is going on there is also going on.
It's not over but this is what's left
Imran Khan wants to arrest them
Sir, whatever is more to him, he is a rebel.
The district is surrounded and these are some of the cases in it.
are from last year too and those from last year
There are some faces of Imran Khan Saheb which are surprising.
Have got some cases done which are
they had no information
Bail not granted and probably Islamabad Police
It was six months before he was arrested.
But the Punjab Police is Imran Khan.
arresting sir in some new way six
And now they are doing this Mathura that
These are the new cases that have emerged in the last 3-4 days.
We have included Imran Khan among them.
After the order of Islamabad High Court
If you can arrest or not
My caste opinion is that Gurj should be used
No one should degrade Punjab Police like this.
This should not be reported to the police so that
Looks like arresting Imran Khan
He is the spice of someone's respect.
Is it someone's orphan and has become a masala now?
If the court stands in the way
Either reduce the court and your infinite
for a few days
put him to sleep and call him after 17 am
What is your overall opinion of Imran Khan?
going to arrest
warrant tamil man go to zubaan pak there
But what a complete scene we saw
Created then arrest from here
The way is from Islamabad High Court.
body tahajjad over tax now here
when they were trying to arrest him
You were also from Islamabad High Court then
Told that the fight ended but there was a
They got relief from this government rate and
Are you fed up with the government's intelligence attacks?
the message goes
consider the case more than anything else
this is what happens now
Look at this Mediterranean, its drain.
No one should have any doubt that this
He wants to do something and he jumps.
Trying to expose Imran Khan
in that his head becomes high again
There is an incumbency in this, see
From last year till now 25 me
All the people who were Imran Khan and his associates till now
have filed a case against
Then take yours out and start reading them.
You will find that 99% of it then
Although in whose previous birth this
This is the genuine reality of the station or you.
The snake comes with great regrets.
It is given by human race but you see
That in the sentence of Lahore also
which is also a statement
And there is another street, that is Ijaazat Choudhary Saheb.
Now brother, I have deposited it in my account there.
There were hundreds of people and hundreds of people saw that
They did not file that they did not have weapons.
If the firing is from the story then you
I can also say your name
from drunkard
Those people will kill, so I gave an example.
and there may be a conspiracy aspect to it
This case is deliberately made in such a way that
Now Imran Khan benefits from it
As 124 these lesser cases were made by Ali
Means against Gangapur while woe to Lahore
Even after the court has given election to 124
you 120
Less than 12 cases against Imran Khan Sahab
Please advise a poet of area 144
You throw this on the Prime Minister
What does it mean to make a case against Flower ji?
Which is to file the case
It is gone and what is left is only that of Thane.
They are being ordered to serve food from above.
Came there is no one to follow up
Wazir admitted that he is on TV all the time.
Mushroom is a relief in giving interviews and IG
It doesn't matter to him what he is.
Who will remove me because I am a scene
to the eyes
Slowly, when the situation becomes like this, then again like this
Lawsuits are painful, so actually
of government and
On top of that, their pomegranate is very high.
Whatever it is, it is so high that it
Someone should also follow the laws of Pakistan
If you don't understand anything in front of you then you will suffer.
And I have been repeatedly saying that you
If Imran Khan has been given release in the court
sir was not at least 17
so right
What will you do if you get relief from the court?
Farooq Saheb has also joined us.
Munni also knows their feelings and opinions
Sir, please say that the one who was there in 17 is very new.
Has bail been given in the case or is it a blanket?
Granted bail, no power to arrest
Why do you think that Imran Khan is making this a law?
Let's look at blanket immunity this way
way to get power
Look, this hand has got mixed into the salad.
There would have been Bedi and perhaps some common man in the court.
So he may not get bail for this also.
But Imran Khan Sahab because this list
Concession is achieved and
Find out the case and
Blanket protection inside suit
And now if Joe sues in Lahore
It has been recorded from him that some Radha
Only Imran Khan Sahab gets the bail.
If he appears in the High Court then it will be normal.
The chapter will also be closed but at this time
If we talk right now then many of us will also
The cases are made with great pains and
it harms someone
Islamabad Police and Punjab were lying
The reason behind this is coming to light within the police.
That is the biggest Bada Dhaba
V is
very quoting from him
being found and being empowered
That arrest should be carried out there
If you know the song number then there
If they get hold of those things, then
Will be done by arrest but if someone like this
There are lawsuits that have been punished but
Address
If so, then they have so much police power.
If you went there after exercising, then what is the reason?
She is coming forward. She is coming forward that
There is a lot of pressure, that is why the case is being filed in Lahore.
Arrested Munni has become inside them
Farooq has been our companion sir with us
Sometimes they give some sound of Najalas
Neither did the justice in the courtroom see you.
Happy Samrat Jigar Jigar Sharif for you
Majmati has gone to a lot of Elamites.
Is Al Tareen of Adla sitting on the chair
This statement of the person is shameful on Adil's face.
there is a dhaba
There were 109 cases of I in the glass which
day which pti
go to the building on alcohol
But 29 was vandalized
Radio to be installed on Swad Motorway today
Pakistan
To
ji has been completed in every way and everything
Imran Khan is like this
had done
reached here through word of mouth
I have met them and just confirmed that
Whatever is in the made throat is very good for them
Didn't care, cleaning was done there too
And now they are completely ready
Majeed which will be established after this which will be non gem
It may be possible to reach the point now.
Whatever they have, their habit will remain which is very bad for the society.
There is an effect because it is mentioned in the RAM that this
time lion i ways
can't give and if they understand then they
Who has talked to his leadership team about the mosque
Is there any chance of arresting him?
can because
He is safe and already ready to speak to High Court
He has also agreed with Sajid
More now if he is here against FM
No action is taken and how can any Majid do this?
His arrest in which he also felt
Mustafa's
That at this time Lahore or Punjab Police
That is to say, this conversation is taking place which
If relief has been received from Islamabad then it is his
If there is no lakh on Punjab or Lahore then
Imran Khan has now become a threat to him
Imran Khan's Lahore trial will go
The application for bail is being made only for protection and
Just all the guests of Islamabad High Court
Jahangir has agreed to the case
I am only concerned about bail applications.
it's finally time
Yes absolutely see Chairman PTI Imran
Khan is now like Tariq Mohammad Jahangir
are already present in the court
The justice he did in Muslim cases
Me in the cleanliness of Miyasan Aurangzeb
Alka De Dress Caption Them in Dress
After his friends got incomplete bail,
Justice Aurangzeb is there, he told this and
Single Rupi Judge Samaj gave another release
Imran Khan in which it was done like this
His arrest was on the 9th day of his life.
Many incidents that happened after
When cases were filed against him, the court
It has been released that such people till 17
He was prevented from being arrested in all the cases.
Now I have some lawsuits from the gym in Lahore.
He is stuck on bail like all Mohammedans.
Sir in Jahangir's court and something in this
There was a technical issue due to which the society
Loyalty has been given, were there any objections?
are being removed and what is after that
society will start again
Details
team to arrest Imran Khan
Present outside Islamabad High Court
Jare has to say that the investigation
Force to arrest Kamran Adil and
Investigation police teams alerted
Imran Khan Jayasi's 10 cases have been filed by police
Imran Khan is hungry for empty noise
The lawsuit has also been named
Islamabad for arrest of Imran Khan
Hey, this is present outside the court.
In this connection it is said that DIG
Investigation Kamran Adil arrest
Have arrived for reinforcements and investigation
Police team has been alerted Imran
Police are interested in 10 fates of Khan Geet
Imran Khan faces lawsuit over Holia ruckus
The name has been chanted in I too, this is the same thing.
Yes, we were doing it earlier also that Punjab
The police comes outside the court outside the court
One more thing is to arrest Imran Khan.
Now especially Punjab Police wants their
As far as Islamabad, up to 17 new
in litigation
Everything, just like you were saying, let's talk about it now.
It has been said that there is no one lakh in Punjab.
So what has happened to him is that now he has taken out
Imran Khan will be threatened but
This matter of calculation means every victory in the court.
If you get bail then throw out the cases.
If we come and become free then one will be all.
One will win and one will be arrested.
If you take someone else's hand then this matter is political.
How will things go now?
See, there is a fundamental difference in this
The cases that would have been made in the absence of Imran Khan
You saw this minister in his case.
Azam Saheb is our Shahbaz Sharif Saheb.
Had been kept inside for some months and his
One reason was also that the hero of his time
There was a law, it seemed like a big thing, it would have been the pride of the day.
If it was so, then this government first
The benefit of term as per the law
Imran Khan sir, he is the second thing.
Imran Khan's case against Jo Ji Kim
They were made with great care and
The proceedings that took place to prepare their case
Only Shashi Kumar was not involved in it.
Whatever was there, he helped them a lot.
And that's why this big thing
Used to prepare a case in which that case was
also b basic him time as you remember
I want to sing a lot of songs
Absolutely stupid man to do but still
in that
used to do planes this way
Three to five months both inside Banda
If you were relieved, sometimes what happens is a lie.
You also need wisdom to speak
You are a lying person, but if you are intelligent then please
If you fall in fear then the legal proceedings
He used to be in the distance of sir if you see him
If we look at it from the legal point of view, it
the quality was better
In reality, this government is far away from him.
If we look at the legal loss, it would be Rs 2.5 lakh.
And poor Kim's quality is number two.
numbers and hence these are then
of happiness and
If you have to face the money gardener then al
Whatever they are doing, I did it for them.
Even before the case, 86 decisions are coming forward.
Even today, basic measures are being taken
Some sources are also being made but this is me
I will give that to Imran Khan Sahab too.
used to file cases under political retribution
But the cases would have been of better quality.
His opponent was in a few months' time.
It was a relief but this Kumud is so incomplete.
Slogans are big, she talks a lot
is but
[music]
The performance is so bad that their legal
The matchsticks are made in Kim's poor quality.
So Imran Khan is benefiting from it
Like you are away from Imran Khan.
I used to prepare cases thoughtfully and in them
There was someone else's involvement too but
This time also in the case being filed
If Imran Khan grabs them then they will become people.
What are the conditions and manners in three days?
There have been attacks and we have seen that too.
It's an example of what we did where Imran
Mine workers arrived and burned
If there is siege, the same target is Imran Khan.
Too
See, during the time of Imran Khan Sahab, a lot
The big difference is that Imran is of this size.
There is a case against Khan Saheb, another thing
A new type of fate has happened, the third
The thing is that Imran Khan Sahab should
The advantage here is that they have great
Accommodation Judiciary has received many
Within the matter, please tell me which case
Of course it's from the Greek
I do serious cases but there are less cases.
Tired of this with people over lawsuits
a crime has been committed and send people in
It has been kept in November of love
A case has also been filed against the government
I am happy that someone is good to someone.
It's a good thing it wasn't thrown at anyone
Not from this government or airplane
Dali and sing the song na us chakkar mein fans
gone and they have tolerated well
It doesn't matter if it's not doing but it's time
The support that Miss Al received and everything that
and did everything in a very naked style
used to go today
That which is better than one lakh
But the combination that is available
And let me also tell you that this is just
Aaliya is sitting above, one from top to bottom
The only order is that accommodation has to be done and its
So what more can be said openly than this?
Power is there to hurt many people
I wonder why you said such a thing?
Why are you talking like this if this is an ongoing thing?
We also live in a country full of thousands of people.
You meet your sources.
you get to know who belongs to what
Is it or what order has been given to whom now?
If the case is in Lahore High Court but
Hum Sagar Pharma diya jaaye story and from
You have to give release and then in a special way
If the benches are also chilled in the Supreme Court
this is happening
What an overwhelming welcome they gave.
The situation is very clear to Khan Saheb.
So the case must be so weak that it is a lie.
That's another thing, relief from the court.
who is milan
Is this time also sir day transmission case
This is what is happening in the court cases, now the cases are happening.
Lawsuits are weak, this is a different matter
There was a news that there was some quarrel among themselves.
There is a conversation taking place which
It is being said that it is too much
Maybe the matter will be settled but after that
That news was also left behind and then the lawsuit
Lawsuits and Bayesians and Collaterals and then
Arrests, this is what is going on.
If someone continues like this then
Do you hope that any matter will be resolved by political group?
we will settle matters together
is born
As much hatred has flooded as much distance
is created wide has been created
I don't know if something like this will happen but
Then how will the translation happen?
Tenure has to be completed after tenu
Elections are to be held, there will be no second government.
If she continues this penance then this penance will become one.
In the common urban place, there is still honey in it.
Looking at Surtal
But now if the government understands that
We held elections in the presence of Justice Saheb.
to get it done or they may suffer political losses
Will go and Imam Khan Saheb will get some benefit
This is how Imran Khan Sahib will understand.
Are they not as per their position according to the law?
but is very strong but inside him
Yes, there was no responsibility due to so much talk
The rule of this government was definitely strong that you
without government
Will get it done and there will be 86 governments in Punjab
how will she be
[music]
Give answers to the government today and they
repeats again and again
Nizam, tell me who is the Supreme Court of this time?
I give now that she is tilted inside her
justice is empty
That you are very eager for the release of Imran Khan
thank you i
Now after the release of Imran Khan you will see things
Are you watching Majid Tarak happening or
You understand that there is a slight drop in temperature
will come
[music]
Imran Khan Saheb will remain absent for now and
them sitting there
Will it be told who is arrested?
Many people from all over the country who are facing poverty
They have been arrested then when they
got to know
Mallika Bukhari has been arrested
Have been arrested and Dr. Shri
If she is arrested then there is a model on her.
Fresh A will go if what I have now is theirs
Something should be done for this and if the matter is ongoing then someone
Just giving name but taking name in something else
You should see Iqbal Sahib also.
was arrested and very
Even if they are wrongfully arrested
Now Aftab doesn't do shows on Jio but whatever
He has been doing shows and he is also a great scenery sir.
He has also been a columnist and once upon a time
have also been reporters
Where did someone find it today that they vandalized it?
Where did they hold elections?
So what is the reason for arresting him?
The matter is ongoing, you Imran Khan
sir and also
It has happened that some people do not accept them together.
They say to make YouTube but whatever
He is a supporter of PTI
If you have also arrested
These lawyers have also been arrested yet
If Imran Khan Saheb is arrested then rest
Neither will you sit with nor will it come from him, that's why
Imran Khan
Sir was found and he was taken out and arrested.
If it weren't for that then it would be a relief.
I did that on the 14th
I will liberate and
[music]
So it's okay, it was me or I was Farooq
May your masala be the justice of
The Supreme Court is there, why did they
Said nice you see you but this mango
Leadership of man's whole world
No doubt has been arrested
We know the reason behind this.
Many people have done this but what I have done
Names have been taken tell me that
Where did Avtar Iqbal burn him?
Why has its leader been arrested?
What answer do you have should I question you?
tha ki rana
But if we don't even ask this question, then we question
Do it or not but people are standing on the streets
People's tongues ask questions
So you can't rock them, you can't even shut them up
can do when
Imran Khan was the pride of his friends.
Khan Saheb, being the person he is, was doing the same thing to him.
Same thing was happening with weddings at the time too.
This is what is happening today but we
have to agree
And the biggest proof of this is that in the last 3
entire pakistan since 4 days
[music]
To post a comment on Twitter
If we try, even that doesn't happen, then this
I don't think this is another thing of Imran Khan.
There is a big distance and if you solve it
If you don't then people will curse you.
It will turn out good, you will always say that this
Whatever happened in this year's succession
Now Lon Lick has his own walker on it and
Javed Latif and Talal Chaudhary and Digar How Joe
He searches repeatedly whenever he presses
They talk about bribery during conferences
do and you know me better that
The only solution is to get relief from there.
it doesn't belong to them, it belongs to someone else
Who is it then you understand that this
₹500 Kahani Na Kahani Hai Noor League Mein
I remember what happened to Talaq Chaudhary Saheb.
I get it done when he was a minister and a broker.
Choudhary and Galiyan ji Choudhary is a stranger
When he spoke against Nawaz, this issue continues.
If there was a policy of Sharif Saheb then it was implemented during his time.
That was his name from his prime minister
maybe tired
I probably took out the clip from the house
Everyone's interview in Prime Minister's office
and he said that this broker
Choudhary and Dhaniya ji Choudhary discussed
Give statement to the Chief of Judiciary
shouldn't be given to them ok
So now the spice is what his policy is.
Couldn't find out what policies Nawaz
Sharif's policy is fine Subhashree
The policy is fine, maybe the remaining house is one
The policy is there, whether it is a house or a house, everything else is the same.
And a third is walking on the third path
The party is trying to become an option
inside but also present inside the party
So the lonely should first
He understood the party's policies at the core.
She did not come, now they will say only that she did Namaz.
The policy is the same, it is our policy but keep an eye on it.
So it is not working in Nawaz Sharif's policy.
If that is the party policy
I told you yesterday also that if it flows then you press
Let's hold a conference against Justice
And you say that is rape and you
Don't know what all the words are in their big
use but inside court
At least with great culture and Islam
The Attorney General sir is very beneficial.
Of
who is with you
Love in computer again and again in outside junction
system
give anything to their elders but who
There are strong problems and flaws that your
At least let's break it with confrontation
We have big news in this, Director Fiya
Waqar Chauhan posted on the rise of Degree Nap
This development division has done
Notification of posting of Bakar Chauhan also
Has been issued and as per this notification
According to Waqar Chauhan Police Service's great
He is a 20 year old officer and has a new degree name.
And do you have any special details?
Is
Jeevkash Chauhan sir is great.
Are experienced police officers and scenery officers.
we wait a lot
[music]
I am getting that DP then this dialogue
He has been doing operations in the police and now
It's like this, I'm that director and it's like that
I am also the first to commit cyber crime.
Now in charge of crime circle
So since his specialty is criminal
That's why his services are there in the investigation.
She had sought it in the canal and now the establishment
Their posting is also to be done in November.
Which is the official notification released
Well, let me tell you that the unique
It is a BJP post but she is of 21 years.
This post is based on experience and
Is
Was telling that Waqar Chauhan is the new DJ.
Hai Nath has been done and his specialty is
In criminal investigation investigation
And also told that although the degree
It is the ode of a 21st grade officer.
These are meant to be of 20 grates but
Looking at their experts
And let us also tell you that Imran Khan
That security is the only bail in the Lahore case
Samad should start once again on the petitions
This has happened before Islamabad High Court.
Justice Tariq Mohammad Jahangir its
termination
Owais tell me what you have finished
Now the Chairman of PTI is Imran Khan
His bail got stuck in the Lahore case itself.
The society is running on petitions and from now on some
Also fear Islamabad High Court Delhi
imran khan's 22 i 10th in shahdara kaise
The court has approved the bail of Willesh and
Police in the country arrest Imran Khan
Justice Tariq Mohammed
Jahangir made this decision to grant bail
The verdict has been given in addition to this in the liver also
The one who is applying for bail of fancy
but the ending is still going on
Of Imran Khan in District Shah Kaise
Police were given a boost from the arrest of 22 more
The district has been rocked by the arrest till now.
How in Lahore due to the arrest of Imran Khan
There is a tax case against Imran Khan
Whose bail is pending and now
Only Imran Khan of 22 leaders has been booked in a case.
Fancy got bail Jalisha Kaise
Imran Khan till 22nd in this connection
Rocked to arrest
Yes, Scenery Saheb cheered Farrukh.
Ikbir Saheb is with us, we also have him as our own.
Muneeb was giving Tajiya, now do whatever.
There is a lawsuit in one of these, how can it be poisoned?
Imran Khan's security only till 22
If the bail is approved then you i.e. the government
So they have to do it again and again
arrest and fox theirs is that
Imran Khan should be arrested at any cost
So the reason behind this arrest is far away in Mudassar.
someone please tell me also
There are political benefits too, i.e.
The people who are son-in-law's are getting perception.
Those who are supporters, if anyone
if arrested if caught
He has become a doctor and you have become weak.
Son-in-law is getting stronger why is he so foxy
In such a situation when Maheshwar in Pakistan
And there are so many more missiles
in front of the government
Pakistani family in Pakistan
At this time we news these updates Apsara
We are making Imran Khan the District Shah
K also approved our fancy in 22
has been done before any new
He is in custody in the absence of a case.
Whatever new case was filed after that
If they are built on top of them, then in
The police have been given a rock from the arrest 17
I can't even arrest you and
Imran Khan was arrested in the case in which
Arrest tomorrow may be considered illegal or even illegal.
The Supreme Court had said in that also
Imran Khan got release today and this too
It is very important to mention here that
Now also on the warrant in this connection
There is talk going on, that's why we are big in this name.
The news has come that the degree has been changed to Nav
The nonsense is gone now Chauhan will be the new degree neo
now our latest news
There will be investigation but Alina is the one who
This was the matter of the police of Punjab and Samvad
The case was that this divorce would not have happened on them
But if you talk about possibilities
So if you don't take Punjab Police, I and anyone else
How can it happen in which no bail has been taken?
He should take help of Islamabad Police in that
power is what we need in punjab
Whoever wants to investigate then this
It remains to be seen how the matter will proceed now.
How many of these cases are valid and
How does Imran get bail in the mosque?
Khan because today we saw that Imran
Khan has got it on bail and 17 I
Like you said, till 17 I started dating someone new.
In cases because this is the incident of Imran Khan
When
You will get relief from here for two weeks
Got relief and then filed new cases
The bouquet has been made in three
arrest Anarkha in any of them
will be taken and major steps in this regard
Whether there is activity or representative feedba present
Soon the Rangers reached there and
Police was also present, there was big news here that
Islamabad Police and Lahore Police at this time
I am going to arrest us
To be the first to do and arrest
They were talking to each other but
Finally the news came from the court that till 17
In any new case i.e. whatever case
These two have been registered
Rahu is of water and hence it is related to this.
Can't even be arrested after 17
kya surat hai all bunti hai kitne majid 17
The case has been registered within
When someone comes to do it, not after 17 but even now
Imran Khan is coming out of the court
So that's but one question this mark very
It's big whether they can be removed
Because just now everyone was telling that
What is going on under legal pressure?
There is a possibility that Punjab Police
take into custody but if he remains
Even if you go home, both of you will still come.
What will be the condition of Surat because this country
Time is like a stand of steel
Where a soldier in our fake government
Peace has been attacked there
There to maintain the appearance
it is punjab
Granted, he didn't say that one day
Later he said that it depends on the circumstances.
This is and if you become like this by 17 then this is
If the decision has been taken, then it remains his.
It is possible that the matter may go till 17th also.
If you can go further then the situation is in your hands.
All decisions will be taken keeping in mind
We have to wait and see what this big thing will be like because
Now one never forgets what was last
Something happened earlier in which Joe was in court yesterday.
Remarks were given on him
Rather you have to express your Jat attitude on top of that.
has been done then you will remember
Not Sadrimoomlikat, yesterday Khat was written as Wazir.
Azam including the arrest of Imran Khan and
His ways had lifted you up along with him
It has never been a problem, it is a Wazir with a jab.
Azam also did auspicious book today and he
Big
He solved this matter in any way he could.
Even if we talk about rapist, you see this
Will it be a political matter or a legal matter?
How is it going because politics is also in India
Floods are coming ahead in their place and these
It is the rule to focus on governance also.
Have to keep a fox on the beauty of the wineskin too
Along with this, it also deals with legal matters.
Let's see which sentence in both these three taxes.
What is the government's rate on this?
also has to be established which will be registered or
Then or to implement them according to the law
is also necessary
The way your leaders scene is doomsday
If he has also been detained
Let's see where this matter goes.
It will be very interesting and at the same time it will be legal
The case is also going on, Shahzad Iqbal Saheb
Joined us and put us in front of them
Shahzad 17 leader Imran Khan should not be appointed as any new
Can't be arrested in case of trial
Then for those who litigate in Lahore
Even if Imran Khan faces even one case till 22
Got a blanket protection.
How do you proceed from here?
And in the last two, these
Sir, please take a look at what happened.
Then do you get the message from everyone?
Look Imran Khan
Sir, you are very lucky that he has come to court.
They have received what they asked for.
That it has been accepted even if Alka is in it
What kind of guarantee should they give or what is there now?
Has he been granted bail for 22 months?
Priya, now they have also received a bill that
He was not arrested even in any new case
I think it can be done
he today
India, this is very impossible for the government.
Should they arrest him for a new case?
Me too because till yesterday also there was so much and
With more soul also said that we
Arrest those outside the Supreme Court
and then he also said night
In TV interviews if tomorrow he
If there is no way we get bail, then we
Will arrest them but I think
life from
Imran Khan and those who become urine cases
Could have happened in that also and if he got bail
There is no power in their enforcement to arrest.
and see anyway
We have grown over the years
You can use someone for political victimization.
let's arrest this should not happen
How can someone be genuine then get the government done?
How can police take action against corruption?
How come you must be arrested
I wonder if they will arrest me.
There will be no benefit from this at this time
Imran Khan is a big relief from substance
If we are achieving then the government will be happy.
Another one of political victimization
This is the case where you will find this story.
The story made you feel that the government
We saw a lot of things even from Akhtiar
That he was not going to do it like this but
Don't know where these things were happening
These cases were going on like Parvez IK
How did it happen at home, then after that it became very
At such a place it seemed as if the government's own descendants
Was not or was not my decision but
things were still happening
See this, the responsibility of government is divided
If something happens in Ismahabad then it will be of loyalty.
It is the responsibility of the government to be in Punjab.
It is their responsibility to stay there and
If this is not happening as per the intention of the government
Then whose intentions are the ruling being done?
Whoever talks about this next, you are on your side now.
I think Imran Khan is giving a hint
Sir, when I was with my relatives, I used to say
Wazir Azam takes any decision without asking me.
Doesn't happen when he comes out of ittedar
Say I wasn't doing this
Everyone would have given the decision in the name of the Army.
Javed Bajwa was doing it clearly.
That's why it is said that I had this Sardar but
If it was not for this love, then we would have been afraid of this rule.
You ask questions again and again and they take ownership.
How did this Kajal Trust get arrested?
Its ownership also remains the government but I
I wanted to see this arrest.
For political victimization if you
If you have to do it then it will create more trouble in the atmosphere.
And I think maybe in Dalton now too
Story or story, this one sense is prevailing
That's why so many cases have been made.
Maybe put some government in it. Understand that some government is there.
Imran Khan arrested in no way
Maybe that's why I'm trying to
that one after the other
There is no benefit in what is being said since time immemorial.
This will happen only if the government is in power now.
to arrest
Effort
You are with us and others, so you also understand this.
It is believed that with great planning in the past
All these cases have happened and if
If someone is kept inside then it will be for 5-6 months.
did, but as much as this government
It is being done again by Mian Javed Latif and
Some hints from Digar Jo Ra Naman Only
do some side still exist some
People are such that by reducing it in a closed manner
On the contrary, the government is suffering losses.
Making natives leaders and vice versa
That is, you are making someone else's position bigger.
So that's why I asked this question
At this time, if something baseless happens, how can I
If arrest is made then the power will be strengthened.
It may be that the government was asking for flowers from the level.
And the level playing field for them is that
Jai Imran Khan disqualified
Do it and then rule whatever is there i.e. New League
Who will go to contest the elections?
Will be ready for what happened against them
Before that in 2017-18, if those 11 fields
are of this
will happen but last
We are a race of using one page like this.
just make him feel he is in power
But there were some other factors also which
she has time together
There is a division visible in it
Perhaps the government's wish seems to be that
They should get some kind of one page so that they can
Can get things done but that one page is like that
No
The government is not getting it at this time
Maybe this is the wish of tomorrow, Marine Nawaz
You can also see what the gentleman tweeted
This is what she was talking about
Things have told you that you are in politics.
DK resigns from his post in politics
If he goes, he is a very tough Kim's.
Twitter but now see the government here
What statement did he make about the mosque earlier?
Said to be getting relief from Lahore High Court
He said that the reason is that he has a son-in-law.
He gets release from then two judges
Quoting one of the Justice Community
The prophet's audio came upon them
He blamed then he saw
Then started blaming him by taking his name.
He made the Supreme Court Justice
Said we are fixing this bench
Like taking care and all these things
I was sure of some virtue, but
In the decision that came yesterday which was of three benches
Apart from Bengal, Mohammad Ali Madad Saheb
From Middle Saheb to whom Ummah gave Pakistan
can make
does not justify in any way any
Political victimization of political leader
Arrest for if there is any how in which
Really don't arrest like corruption
How then is it ok to understand something but like this
Not at all heaving sad was this one
The task is being divided in the tongue park
Tamil of arrest warrants
Then Imran Khan recognized it as his own.
and there Imran Khan was sitting inside
You know no one could reach him then
Was arrested later but Imran Khan
Got the release so this one is going to be a taser
Your thoughts on Imran Khan Dr. Untouchables
What is the reason for this? Is it the government's own fault?
haste or the system's own failure
Because of which this is happening that Imran Khan
's style of politics is
Firstly, this is a failure of our system, Imran.
Khan himself used to say that justice is for all
should be equal but in some cases
Like he has got the release that a common man
So we can't get it, we'd rather leave it to the common man.
who are great leaders from our place
If you don't tell them it's a political donation then they will.
The weakness of the system is that it
They were found there despite a police warrant.
Couldn't arrest but I think
Imran Khan
This lesson has also been learned because
First you are the receiving and first there is the paying.
From the other side they probably know that if
I
If you want to protect yourself from them then I am a lad.
I can only tell and he is loving the fight.
And like him they are trying to save him
You see even today he said this to them in the court.
The fire that has been fired, the commotion is going on.
They surround him with each other, I don't
Imran Khan helped Suna in Namaz
That thing you said yesterday that you don't do to me
He also did not say so before that
We also saw when Jaban was arrested in the park.
That's why we came here to do whatever is there, bye.
If an attempt was made to stop the force,
Khayal is a style of politics
Pakistan ways did you understand that I am a joke
I am from MMA through
Discuss details but will remain with us
This news reaches you too and your
Even the spectators are against Imran Khan
Hifazati in Lahore decade Gardi case
New bench for society on bail application
The task has been given, live representative.
News Owais Yusuf joined Jaidev
Practice Tell me what details you have
On the other hand, Imran Khan kept getting release after release.
and some fear from you
know about the relationship
has spoken
New bench given for bail in case
This new division is all banks.
like mohammed jahangir
Will be like the city of donkey's back which is Lahore
Muslims in
on
Before K, the society was running on a single platform.
Now the division will end in the bank
if i get arrested
He told me to do it, I was out
I will control them
what has been said
Yes, see when Imran Khan in his Lahore
Fancy bail granted in a case and
Whatever Gardi's case is about, his society's
from division bank
I got a little scared when the nonsense came out
Court from Chairman PTI Imran Paan
report camera court rope gossip
And this is what he had to say if I
If arrested then Amal will have phone control
Will do, he said if I am out
Imran Khan will control the people
Have to say and rooms in the court of the airport
There is some fear in you from the photo and only from the mouth.
they have chatted
They were telling that not only Imran Khan
There is a case of panic against the blacksmith.
A new bench was set up for him in
Is it about bail but Imran Khan
Rashmi openly talked to the camera
Imran Khan said in and during the court
that if they arrest me then I will be out
Who will control the crowd if I go out?
If I am there, I will control the crowd
that if they arrest me then the public
Who will control if I am out?
Now I will be able to control mango Imran Khan
Darshan of Lahore against
The new bench has been given hard for you
and took it off the camera
This news has come that
Wazir Azam definitely attended Sadarat Kavin's meeting.
The second one which is far away has never started.
Somewhere the last one has started again, Wazir
Azam's efforts in this regard are impressive
Know Ayaz Akbar Yusuf with us
Are
But has there ever been a glass session before?
In which Ann made remarks in court yesterday
Imran Khan went to meet him
What has been decided yet and what has happened?
look at the last one
As we reported to you earlier that
The rest of the winners were far away in the first session.
Was in it, the remaining 9 I were there today and
along with the arrests and
The decision of the Supreme Court is based on questions
so much more and also you know
Which are on government courses and which are on our courses?
What we have done on the installation above
then with this again with this
It should happen during this time so that the matter can be controlled
This should be done, these are being fired under control.
Yes, but then quoting Musarat, he said that
can be noticed and better than this
Because the government is this PDM etc.
Only one scoundrel needs a forum because it exists
Whatever is there for the crops of this Kim is there.
There will be no approved form, why not listen?
I am there, please meet him too.
For the society which is second to us
Two were placed that ever happened against pedia
is the one which is still at some stage after its completion
The treatment of this convoy has started again
that it was put forward in this last
Will know if there is an emergency which can go
There is article under that and if to do
Is
What will be those grounds and so that
All our things should be a board, something like this.
never want to decide which if someone
pf
If we did airport then all these issues would be there in that also.
was placed in front of the water that had fallen
It is the attitude of the court that claims
The government has those 22 questions with them.
Tafside Mushairas have also been performed in which
Those decisions have been taken earlier by the cabinet.
From a distant decision, now inside this distant second
Which is an open forum keeping all things in front
But there will be discussion and this means news or flowers
Sarfaraz of the Ithari Jamaats who was not found
In the conversation I had with the emergency
What does it mean when it comes to dirty talk?
Was it farmed or raided?
given
The lodge is that in which the PDM and the liver
Those who join hands are also in favor of this because
At present the government understands that the government
I am trying to do it the right way.
Being allowed to prepaid immediately
All that is there has been used.
Whatever the demand situation is at this time, that too
The entire country is in front of you and so is Majeed.
The government is predicting that
The circumstances are going, it may be Majid who
He is Jain towards him who later controls
With a hard hand for them
You know that at this time most
First morning in Punjab and then here
Some of you in area 245 in Islamabad
The thought that is present above the ground at this time
This is all from the matter that you know
are not in the routine and they are a bit like
Situations have arisen where a round
It is possible that if their comrades on the police side
If used, the government will have a
This is a good forum and this is a good situation for them.
Emergency prayer from the question that he was born
You can decide now what is after this
If the [ __ ] can't do that then this is why
This is very important, this is last, this is second
This proposal has now been uploaded to this session.
Everyone else is sure about him and Wazir Azam.
How many conveyances are there after that if any
If a decision is taken then it will be taken to Parliament.
I will take Jai to his Toshi Ayaz
Those who watch you will remain with us
This is big news which will come almost
The last words of Wafa Ki Kavin are arriving
The second is started by and in
The agenda is that the PM who has some fear before you
There was a celebration of emergency in the country.
benefited from the benefits of
He had a conversation with the Ittehadis regarding this matter.
Now sometimes I will say no and sometimes I will say no
there will be a good night
Shahzeb Badi Hum news is coming at this time that
First from near the emergency in the cabinet
The following discussion took place again Mian, well done Sharif.
Said that first I will talk to other groups
I should do it from there also Ayaz is telling me that
Got green signal and again today
If it has started then tell me about the emergency.
The envelope will be a huge peeup
How will they handle auto emergency?
You give the assembly issue one more year
What stability has been achieved in the last 1 year?
Is it an emergency that you will wait for one more year
If you take it bigger, you will see stability.
Will see directly what is the matter at this time
are straight if anyone thinks the team
If you talk to me from Rajasthan then this
It will be less if we arrest them.
Setup will come, he will not come because mine
Sir, I have said these things to you
Have you seen anyone till date that he can bring the country to this
When Wazir-e-Azam will show his face like that
But even the bank will not give because then
This is what happens to them, I called the opposition brother.
no competition
that's all i have
If you want to lock it then put it in yellow.
So Khan Saheb is one in politics.